hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be going over three big things the first
one is 2011 what you can't expect from
the youtube channel and also the website
i know many people that watch the video
is also freak with the website so i do
want to let you know what is up coming
for the new year second thing i do want
to talk about is frequently asked
questions as you can imagine i do get
asked these same questions over and over
so i figured it'd be a good opportunity
to make a video and answer some of those
common questions that I get asked a lot
and it may answer a lot of your
questions if you haven't asked already
and then the last thing I do want to
have a giveaway so definitely make sure
you check out the end of the video we
will be giving away some prizes so first
thing we'll go ahead and get into it
what you can expect from 2011 first
thing I want to talk about is the
YouTube channel there's going to be
three big things that you're going to
see for me towards the beginning of the
year now these could change towards the
end of the year and again I'll always be
throwing in new stuff but the three big
things are going to be opening there are
a few big openings that haven't touched
on at all so I definitely want to get
those out of the way and then after that
I'm really going to be focusing on
variations of some of the popular
opening so you can let me know kind of
what variations you guys want to see but
as you can imagine I get asked all the
time hey Kevin I play the Sicilian
defense I play the Kings gambit I play
the XYZ opening can you give me some
different variations in some in-depth
videos on those so that's exactly what
I'm going to do on the website once you
click on Sicilian defense you'll see at
the bottom once those are uploaded
you'll see different links where you can
go in and watch more variations second
thing is going to be famous games I'm
asked all the time to analyze more
famous game so if there's a famous game
that you really enjoy want someone to
analyze it go ahead and send that to me
I'll look at it and I may make a video
on it if not I do have a lot of famous
games that I grew up watching analyzing
and some that I just find time to time
that I think would be pretty fun to make
a video on so feel free to send me some
videos but I'll definitely be making a
lot more famous game analysis also i'm
asked to make videos on my own games so
i'll definitely be kicking out some of
my own games on youtube
and analyzing those I may even no
promises but may have a series set up
with JRuby or Jerry over at the chest
network and try to get some games in
with some of the YouTube commentators I
think that would probably one of the
greatest things that YouTube's ever seen
as far as the chess world as far as the
website you can expect many of the same
updates obviously I'm going to be
putting a lot more videos on the website
this year there's going to be another
makeover that goes on the website also
i'll be adding more puzzles i'll be
adding more features a lot of more
interaction with the websites going to
be added obviously again any input if
you have something that might make the
website better definitely feel free to
let me know next thing we're going to
talk about is frequently asked questions
again a lot of people ask me the same
questions over and over and while I do
not mind at all responding to all the
emails and questions that i do get i
think it might be very beneficial if i
go and answer some of the most
frequently asked questions that I get
day today the first one is what chess
software do i use specifically in my
videos or to analyze my games and i use
again this is going to be in the
description below so if you don't know
what I'm saying or can't remember you
can just look below and it will be there
but I use deep rybka for aquarium and I
get that from chess central.com if you
haven't been to test central comm
fantastic place to get great chess
software if you're looking for chess
sets they have tons of stuff but this is
where i got mine it's deep rybka for
aquarium it's pretty fantastic and that
leads me into the next point which can i
analyze a chess game if you send it to
me now typically if I analyze a famous
game these videos that you'll see all
the time those typically take me about
four to five hours to analyze myself
really get in in-depth really try to
find some great information for you guys
to study the game honestly I just don't
have that kind of time every day when
someone sends me again to kind of look
at but going back to the chest software
chest software if you have good software
it can analyze your game for you so you
really
need me next question I get asked a lot
do i play on chess.com the answer is yes
my name is Kings gambit 33 send me a
friend request I didn't use to play a
lot but I have started to play quite
often so send me a friend request if
we're on the same time definitely feel
free to shoot me a game invite and we'll
get it going next question will i put
the answers to the chess puzzles on the
website and the answer is an emphatic no
and i say that only because early on I
realized if I just put the answer
someone's going to come to the website
do a puzzle and maybe work on it for
five minutes and after five minutes give
up look at the answer say oh yeah that
was pretty cool and move on to the next
one that's not the intention of the
website the website is to really help
you improve your game and the only way
you're going to improve your game is to
get in situations where you're not
comfortable you're not sure what you're
going to do but you figure it out that's
really the only way if you just go off
the chest knowledge that you have right
now you're not going to improve that's
just common sense so the goal is to look
at the chest puzzle if you can't figure
it out on your own click on the hint if
you still can't figure it out then you
can email me and I can give you a bigger
hint or I can give you the answer but
definitely try to spend more time on the
puzzles before you just email me and say
hey Kevin will you put up the answers
because I'm going to respond until you
know now the last thing I'm asked a lot
is are the chest DVDs on the websites
different than what is on the website
and the answer is now they are as of
January 1 2011 I launched a new set of
DVDs the regular price is 79 they are
currently on sale for fifty dollars it
is a 10 disc DVD set a little bit
different than the old set and as you
can tell if you hover over any of the
dvds it will tell you specifically what
is on that DVD and it will say
specifically if it's DVD exclusive so
you can see in this one all these are
going to be DVD exclusive on some of
them they may say new examples that just
means I completely remade a new video to
kind of give better examples that I
thought you know did a better job than
the videos that
we're on the current website so feel
free to come here if you haven't already
seen this or if you're wondering all I
know a lot of people ask me to make a
lot more content and put those on some
DVDs that they could purchase there you
go right here currently they're on sale
for fifty dollars last thing I want to
talk about is the giveaway every now and
then I like to give away some free stuff
in this case since I do have a new set
of dvds I'm going to be giving away two
of the new sets of DVDs again it doesn't
matter where you live i will ship
internationally and it will be
completely free all I ask again 2011 I
really want to make the website and the
youtube channel as awesome as I can and
a lot of that comes from feedback pretty
much ninety percent of the stuff you see
on the website or the videos comes from
feedback from you guys so the best way I
know to have a giveaway is for someone
to fill out this survey the link will be
in the description it will not be on the
website it's going to be specifically to
those people that actually watch all my
youtube videos on youtube so definitely
check it out click on the link it's
SurveyMonkey it's going to take you
absolutely no time at all it's seven
questions at the very bottom you can see
what is your youtube name go ahead and
fill that out i'm going to be randomly
sort of selecting from those make sure
you are subscribed to the chest website
all know if you're not and you obviously
won't win but definitely feel free to
give me some great feedback if there's
stuff you want to see added to the site
if there's something that you don't like
that you do like that you think would
improve it definitely feel free to let
me know if you don't fill it out you're
not going to be eligible and I know if
you fill it out or not because it comes
directly to my email so fill all the
questions out even if it's one or two
words just fill it out to humor me and
to be entered for the DVDs you have
until Monday morning when I get up to go
to work I don't know what time that is
but as soon as I get up from Monday I'm
going to get up go to my computer and
cancel the survey so you have until
Monday morning central time zone United
States to submit your answer so
hopefully you guys enjoyed the
video hopefully to answer some of your
questions hopefully are pretty excited
about the youtube channel for 2011 all
the great videos that are going to be
coming out hopefully you're excited
about the website definitely feel free
do the survey hopefully as many people
as can that will win the DVDs obviously
if you purchase the dvds and you win the
dvds i will refund your money so if
you're interested in the dvds go ahead
and you can purchase them now and then
if you win i'll just give you your money
back so see you guys in the next video
and feel free to leave any comments or
you can email me if you have a specific
question thanks guys